as Jim Breuer and I'm answering the
internet I am currently on my comedy
tour live and let laughs go to official
Jim Breuer calm B ar e u ER BR e ue are
very simple come to a city near you
would you rather have a dick as your
nose or a nose as your dick oh my god I
think I would
mmm dick as my nose oh you know what
yeah I'm gonna go with a as long as I
could still you know have the eyes go
back in my head at the same feel I'm
gonna go with the nose by my dick and
I'll tell you why because a dick on your
nose it's a lot of work you know she's
like it's a lot of work it's a lot of
work where this yeah this you have
nothing to lose you've nothing to lose
down here yep nose you know small nose
black probably a little more sensitive
smell this this is you know people bump
into it you could slam it in the door by
accident
oh it's nice slam the door my dick you
know people could bump into you you're
in line dude you take some my back back
up if you can party with one sports team
in history 86 minutes I think I think my
I think my clothes would still be
missing
would you rather only be able to use
magazines report or have to sit on the
toilet anytime you have to pee oh I
would well first of all I come from the
age where you needed magazines and to be
honest with you I sit on the toilet
when I piss because I live in a
household women so sitting on the toilet
when I piss is no problem it is worth
sitting talking pissing then have four
female voices going dad any time one day
you're pissing ma that gets gross spills
all over it's on the side how do you get
it on the side can you tell me that I
want to clean it when I lift it it's
behind it how do you do it's not worth
it sit and piss you have to have sex
with the girl of your dreams but they
hold a press conference after rating
your sexual performance do you do it
now I'm married so I have to go to my
single days yeah I'll take that press
conference because no matter how bad it
is because as long as I still have a
voice at that press conference I'm gonna
I'm I'm gonna take if I'm going down I'm
taking it down with me I'm exploiting
every little thing about her oh you
think she's hot
he's hot she burps and farts throughout
the entire whatever I ain't afraid of
you come loudly every time you fart or
fart loudly every time you come oh my
god I'm gonna go with the fart every
time you come how exciting is that
that's my love call to you and quite
honestly whenever I described that
that's the noise I use anyway like see I
just came all right if you were homeless
which city would you live in San Diego
would you rather have hot dogs for
fingers or hamburgers as butt cheeks
hotdogs I'm gonna go with hamburgers as
buttcheeks yeah but you can't play it
you donkey with hot dogs would you
rather [ __ ] a goat and nobody knows or
you don't [ __ ] a goat but everyone
thinks you did
oh I'd [ __ ] the goat nobody knows I've
always wanted to try something like that
at least once before I go down if you're
gonna have one person narrate do
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be
Bob Murphy let you know what your
audience not gonna know Bob Murphy is so
you know what I'll tell you who Susan
almond of the Yankees oh my god John
look at Jim Breuer Oh
his technique John I didn't see that
coming no pun intended something he just
spotted if you had to pick one person to
be the ambassador for the human race to
meet aliens but Joe Rogan you get a
hundred thousand to put your baby in a
microwave Jesus for three seconds do you
do it now 2.5 million maybe no would you
take four million dollars Oh God
to be uncatchable never no no and I'll
tell you why
because it doesn't matter if someone
just accuses there's eight billion
people go did you hear he I think it
happened know who would win a fight a
Navy SEALs brain or a toddler's body or
a toddler's body in a seals body a Navy
SEALs brain
you see like I know how to [ __ ] kill
you hmm I'm going with the baby if it
has nuts the baby can win the nuts can
take out any size when I got a big
silverback gorilla in front of me which
I've had in my time and I felt
threatened I immediately go I just look
at his thighs and his groin area and see
how fast I can go at it and bite it and
watch that Godzilla come down nice on my
size matter of fact true story I have a
family member
silverback gorilla he was surfer for
years shoulders monster wrestler UFC we
were at a family function we were
getting a little too crazy at too many
cocktails he thought it'd be fun to
wrestle me I'm in my 40s I'm a little
fat and chubby but I come from the
street he doesn't he had me down on the
floor you know I did I stuck I called it
the shock and awe hand to God took my
thumb jammed it in his ass he was in
complete shock slapped him and then took
him down
when in doubt thumb to the [ __ ]